[موسيقى]
ما وراء الافلام مع محمود النجار على
العربيه
[موسيقى]
صعوبه جدا في التنفس علشان كده طول الفيلم
بتستخدم انبوبه اكسجين وبقت هي والانبوبه
الجزء اللي يتجزاؤه من بعض بيبدا الفيلم
بحكايه من هيزال عن الروايات وازاي ان
دائما مش بتحكي القصه او الحقيقه كامله
وان العلاقات الرومانسيه ليها شكل معين
واطار ثابت بس هي هتحكي خلال الفيلم عن
علاقه مختلفه وقصه رومانسيه بس نهايتها
حزينه
من بدايه الفيلم بيظهر عليها اعراض
الاكتئاب ودكتورتها بتوضح لها ان ده عرض
جانبي مصاحب للسرطان في هذا اللي بترد
بسخريه
للموت وبعدها بتصر امها انها تحضر جلسات
دعم نفسي
لكنها في النهايه بتحضر وبتشوف قد ايه هي
حاسه
بتبدا الاوضاع تتغير مع هيزل لما بتكون
رايحه للمجموعه وبتخبط عن غير قصد في واحد
من الحضور اللي هيفضل طول الجلسه بيبصلها
بتركيز وبعدها هتتعرف على بطلنا ثاني
[موسيقى]
فقد رجل من رجليه ولكن مكانها ساق صناعيه
وبيحضر الجلسات علشان يدعم ذلك بطلنا
الثالث ذاك فقد عين بسبب السرطان وهيفقد
الثانيه قريب ويبقى اعمى بالكامل بيحكي
ازاي في الجلسه انه خلاص قريب جدا
بس اللي مصبره على كل ده عنده حبيبته اللي
بتدعمه وهتفضل معه رغم كل حاجه وبعد ما
بيخرجوا من الجلسه ينزل هتشوف اذاك مع
حبيبته وقد ايه هم بيحبوا بعض
تفكيرها على فيلم وبالفعل بتروح معه وقتها
جدا بكل تفاصيل هزل ويحاول لاحلامه فمثلا
نزل المفضل انمي بريال افولكيشن ذا فولت
ان اورز ليفان هويتنز عن بطله مصيبه
بالسلطان الكتاب بينتهي بموت البطله من
غير ما نعرف مصير اللي حواليها ايه وده
اللي كان شاغل هيزل دائما اجسوس بيهتم جدا
لرغبه هيزل كريس انها تعرف ايه اللي حصل
للابطال وبيبعث ايميل الكاتب علشان يسال
كل الاسئله اللي نزل نفسها تعرف اجابتها
وبالفعل فان بيرد عليه وهيحكي اجسس لايزل
عن الايميل وهتفرح جدا وهتتحمس تبعت
الكاتب لكنه هيقول له انه مش هيقدر يرد
على كل الاسئله دي هنا وبيعزمهم يظروف في
بيته في امستردام وهنا هتكون نقطه تحول في
علاقته
بتتحمس جدا لزياره كتبها المفضل بيظهر
عقابات كثيره
جدا وهتتعب جدا دكاتيرتها بيرفضه صفارها
تماما هيزل بتحبط جدا وبتحس انه حظها سيء
قوي في دول في منظمه بتحقق امنيه واحده
لكل مسبب سرطان وهيزل اخذت امنيتها دي وهي
عندها 13 سنه لما تظهر عقبه الفلوس مش
هتقدر تسافر وقتها اوجستس بيقرر يشاركها
امنيته وبيطلب انهم يسافروا امستردام وعلى
الرغم من رفض الاطباء لسفرها بس والدتها
بتحقق امنيتها وبيضبطوا كل حاجه علشان
الرحله دي في رحلتهم في مستردام او جاستس
بيعترف بحبه الهزل وبيروحوا متحمسين جدا
علشان يقابلوا الكاتب لكن المقابله دي
هتصدمهم لانهم هيلاقوا راجل متعجب جدا
ومتكبر وبيعملوا معامله سيئه قوي لدرجه ان
هيزل البنت الرقيقه الجميله والهاديه طول
الفيلم هتصرخ فيه وتسيب المكان
[موسيقى]
اللي هي تعبت فيه هو كمان تعب وكشف
نشوف ان السرطان رجع مش بس رجع ده انتشر
في جسم كله وقتها
فصل من رحله علاجهم هما الاثنين ودعم
ايزاك اللي بقى اعمى فعلا وحبيبته وسابته
قبل العمليه ايه اللي حصل بعد كده حياتهم
كانت عامله ازاي هل عاشوا وقدروا ينتصروا
على السرطان ولا ماتوا ده اللي هتكتشفه
لما تشوف الفيلم انا عايز اقول لك ان في
سنه 2014 بس كان في اكثر من مليون و600
الف حاله سرطان جديده تم تشخيصها واكثر من
500,000 حاله وفاه بالسرطان في الولايات
المتحده وما زال السرطان من اكتر الاسباب
شيوعا للوفاه في الولايات المتحده الفيلم
2012 كتب المؤلف قصه حب ومؤثره ومثيره جدا
شوفنا ازاي وجود اصدقاء بيخفف
فارق معايا انه خسر عينه لانه جاستن دائما
موجود شوفنا الصراع مع الوقت وازاي
بيخلينا عايزين نكون مؤثرين في العالم
ولكن مع الوقت بنكتشف اننا عايزين نكون
مؤثرين في حياه شخص واحد بس شوفنا
لانهزامات ازاي بتحول الشخصيات اللطيفه
الهاديه لشخصيه حاده جدا وازاي القلم
بيطلب ان احنا نحس به او زي ما اتقلت في
الروايه بين
ديماند وشفنا الاباء وخوفهم ودعمهم
ورعايتهم المستمره لابنائهم السرطان مرض
اللعيب يكون مقدم حقيقي للموت مصابين
السرطان دائما في صراع مع الوقت لان ده هو
عدوهم الوحيد ولو الامل
[موسيقى]
قلت نوع ستارز نهايته مختلفه البطل مش
هيتجوز البطله مش هيعيشوا في تبات ونبات
هتكون نهايتهم مختلفه لكنها هتاثر على
الكل الحقيقه مهما احكي لك لازم تشوف
الفيلم بنفسك وتعرف ايه اللي حصل بس ايه
رايك دلوقتي اقول لك على كذا اختلاف ما
بين الفيلم والروايه للمنتخب في الكتاب
بيتذاكر الفرقه الموسيقيه هيكتب ودي
الفرقه الموسيقيه المفضله الاوجستس ولا
تذكر في الفيلم في الكتاب اجصص عنده 17
سنه في الفيلم عنده 18 في الكتاب بتدور
هيزعل على رساله اوغستس انما في الفيلم
بيديها لها ممكن تكون بتسال هل الفيلم
جولدن 2014
[موسيقى]